foreign
happy
come here come here buddy
it's Ben's 45th birthday so he and the
boys are down on the point and I
got what are you guys doing hey Mom what
are you doing I got a little surprise
for you oh my goodness apparently here
take the plates thank you Happy 45th
birthday honey I love it did you cook it
no 100 not did you bake it store bought
baby thank goodness the way we roll here
the river
Chase light them up old is the dinosaurs
is that what you're saying
happy birthday to me
[Music]
hello hello hello
well look at this room full of color and
cute little noises today we have some
love birds in the clinic
lovebirds are just what they sound like
those two thump up against each other
kiss on each other they kind of settle
in and love each other for life
I feel the love
I've always loved Birds they were just
so cute and the way they would snuggle
we got one and then we found another one
and then we found another one
we just kept going they're kind of like
chocolates you can't just have one
exactly their average lifespan is 20 to
30 years you'll be well off into college
and these birds will still be around
there's no such thing as an empty nest
for YouTube
you want to tell me who everybody is
this
this is honey she is a peach face and
her mate Junior then this is another
couple Peach face Johnny here he's got
the darker Peach and this is Serene
they're not necessarily bonded yet they
don't know if they like each other yet
or not they're just dating right now
they're dating okay and then who do we
have here this is mac and nanner they
are siblings we're not sure if they're
boy or girl and that's why we're here
today if they are male female I will
want to split them because I won't want
to take the chance of them having babies
sure and if Serene and Johnny don't hit
it off and we have a female male here
maybe we need to do a little swapper
exactly
and you brought everybody up kind of for
a toenail trim too and just a good look
over and just a good look over okay
let's go ahead and start our work on
sunny
all right there's a long one wow in the
wild a bird's nails are worn down just
from flying around to the trees and
grabbing onto things we're all done with
you all right it's Junior's turn for
nail trim but in captivity they just
don't have that same wear so we've got
to help them out with a nail trim okay
what did just happened here who's next
this is the dating couple these are
going to be a challenge
easy easy these little birds are very
small but they pack quite a punch with
that beak oh she does bite hard you
little stink baby
I'm glad I got these bumps on okay
Johnny's all done
oh
she had to get one last little bite you
little stinker five down two to go Mac
and Nana are here to find out if they're
male or female correct in some species
of birds you really can't tell if
they're male or female just by looking
at them
I know honey I'm sorry we actually need
to take a DNA sample send it into the
lab and then they can sex them for us
everybody's got a toenail trim they all
look good they're all in good shape we
have mac and nanner's DNA sample all
collected we should have some results
fairly quickly and we'll get some
answers for you great
who first
it's a very tiny needle
do you like cookies
oh they were like well now you're
talking our language
oh very brave
hello hi a dog Hi how are you guys good
so what do you got in here we've got
Lily
Lily is a super senior Bengal cat she's
14 years old already Bengals are just a
little bit more of everything
they play a little more they get a
little bigger than other cats
hi sweetheart
and when they're mean they're mean
she gets pretty ferocious stuff so watch
myself a little bit wash your hands okay
because she will bite
what's going on with Lily she hasn't
gone to the bathroom since Sunday oh my
early morning so for four or five days
now she hasn't gone to the bathroom
correct okay that's kind of scary to me
we also noticed she's not eating as much
as normal and eating very little dry
food constipation in any animal is
life-threatening because they feel
constipated they have a belly ache and
then they don't want to eat if any
animal can't evacuate that feces it can
get toxic and of course harm them all
right we'll start our exam here
heart sounds great let's take a look at
her teeth if we can
oh
I found a rotten one you did
there are some serious gingivitis
she's definitely got a big infection in
that tooth root and that's probably what
you're seeing with her not eating that
hard food anymore because it hurts when
you have a sore tooth you don't want to
eat and of course when you don't eat you
don't poop and I think that's exactly
what's going on with Lily here let's
talk about a super senior kitty having a
dental
because they have to be under anesthesia
for this I think the best thing to do is
take our x-ray see what the constipation
looks like but we definitely have to do
a kidney profile liver profile just to
make sure everything is good we have to
be very aware that she's older Kitty and
all the precautions need to be taken and
before we would ever think of sedating
her
[Music]
doesn't want to be handled today let's
get some blood drawn and then if you can
help me do an X-ray next that'll be
great
[Music]
her true Bangles coming out we got the
blood
now let's go get an x-ray I know there's
a tooth problem here but I gotta take an
x-ray just to be very thorough and make
sure there's not an intestinal blockage
or something else causing her not to
poop I mean there's feces in her colon
but it's not like oh my goodness she's
full of of feces so that's a good sign I
don't think she's constipated right now
so that's good and now we're going to
wait on her blood work and see what that
looks like okay
not bad for an older Kitty she's got
great blood work Lily's blood work looks
really good so I'm very confident that
we can do the dental get her eating
again that'll make her poop and this
problem should resolve when a kitty is
totally constipated I'll see hard fecal
ball after hard fecal ball after hard
fecal ball I don't see that I also
checked the blood work and it looks
great you guys
should be able to metabolize all of
those anesthetic drugs just fine and get
rid of them because that's what I really
worry about I would like to try some
canned food at home that we're going to
get you a little Smorgasbord see if she
can keep eating a little bit at a time
until we can get that darn tooth and
maybe more teeth extracted Lily you were
a good girl today you dealt with a lot
of stuff glad neither one of us are
bleeding too bad we got through it
foreign
do you remember the last time you were
at shoot some Fest John yeah well at one
time that I remember but all the other
times I don't remember maybe I had too
much beer I don't know something shoots
and Fest is an awesome Festival that
happens in the little town of Beau
Valley right near us in Cedar County
it's our local German festival that we
have once every five years it's been
going on for about a hundred years no
it's 125 years this year yeah so a
little over 100 years this is this
thing's been going on and it is a blast
so dad for the shoots and Fest Parade I
would love to ride Missy but she's got
some baggage this year
we've got a new baby on our farm her
name is Abel in order to have her be a
better horse and get used to people it
would be a great thing to get her in a
parade she's gonna need a little
training do you have any tricks for this
we always saddle up the mama and tie the
baby to the mama they always want to
follow Mom anyway well I think Missy
would be up for that we'll get this
thing started how about that
You Got The Touch still dad he's still
got the touch on the ground
let's see how she moves around here
she doesn't have to be perfect at this
she just has to follow her mom but she
also can't be zipping off into the crowd
or running through people that wouldn't
be good for her anybody yeah you're
doing good
nice girl well there's a reason we
called you down here today Dad I'll give
you 25 dollars for
for the first time this is going
unbelievable you and her are really
hitting it off this is a good baby maybe
fifty dollars
[Music]
come on Mabel
look at there
that one better than I thought yeah
Mabel really accepted everything she's
leading well this could go great look at
that baby lead
I think I'll give you a hundred and
fifty dollars now that she's trained
since
prize for you
all right hold on I'll be right back it
wouldn't be fun if we're in a big German
Heritage parade and we're wearing jeans
and tank tops oh my goodness
I hope you got the right size he's got a
pretty big head I got you guys
you guys
go home
what is this front that's for you to
find out we'll see you in a few days for
the parade honey I'll take your hat are
you gonna go for a ride down the road
I'll take her for a spin okay
okay
let me run this by Ben because he's
standing right here
what happened how bad is he
start canceling other appointments this
is a crazy day we walked into pretty
much a normal appointment schedule and
all of a sudden two people have called
with dogs hit by cars what size is dog
is Eddie oh Eddie's a little guy he's
like 25 30 pounds he's a little rat
terrier how big is the other dog the
picture I got on the phone was about 40
pounds this is not a usual day anymore
you never know what we're dealing with
here so
um let's get this going
looks like the one dog just pulling in
this has now become something that we're
trying to handle the best we can
sorry this happened yeah yeah she just
was hot
she got underneath the back of the tire
okay Dolly came out with me to help fix
fence and she was laying in that little
bit of a water puddle right where the
pickup was parked we backed up to go get
some more wire and didn't know she was
there so
has she been able to move or walk or
anything no no okay she's just been
laying there and yeah okay we're gonna
go take a quick x-ray of her back in and
just see where the damage is
whenever a hit by car dog comes in it's
usually a matter of me getting right to
the X-ray machine and taking some
pictures all right Dolly's here so that
I can see exactly what is hurt on the
dog before we do a lot of manipulation
and pulling around because without that
knowledge I could maybe do more damage
than good
she's at least alert that's a good thing
she's a little bit pale but it just
happened she hasn't moved since she got
hit okay did you pinch your toes she can
move the left she's not responding to a
deep pinch on her right hand
dang it it really is disheartening to me
whenever I squeeze on an animal's paw
and they show me no response whatsoever
because that means potentially paralysis
Dr Ben Dr Aaron we have their dog Eddie
just got here we gotta have valep here
what are you doing
hi Eddie
okay let's get Eddie into oxygen
and he looks pretty critical here
he's really pale he's he's purple so
he's not oxygenating real well
compared to Dolly the Dog Ben is with
Eddie's in an extremely rough shape he's
not particularly conscious he's
obviously in shock let's slow that fluid
right down just a bit more it's clear
that he has some definite wounds on him
he's got extremely bad swelling over his
hips and lower back it's not a good
situation for Eddie
okay
you're being very brave Dolly good girl
[Music]
oh my goodness
I've seen pelvic fractures but this is
beyond belief Dolly totally crushed one
side of her pelvis into the other this
is one of the worst pelvic fractures
that I've ever seen this is really
really bad though but because Dolly's a
young healthy dog I give her some hope
young bones always heal better than old
bones
it's all right Eddie okay
Ben are you
are you I know what I need to know if
you guys need to take an x-ray I can
jump off the table quick yep we do
I know what Dolly's skeleton looks like
now I've got to shave her so I can see
if there's any open wounds or what the
heck else is going on here
well it's a good sign that we don't see
any blood yet
we gotta watch for blood coming out of
her vulva
blood out of her rectum an open wound
would let bacteria be introduced into
this wound and that complicates this by
a thousand times
pelvic fractures are funny because they
are very sharp pieces of bone that are
right near a lot of very important
organs so if that pierces into the colon
or the bladder or any of those
structures in the back that can be
immediately life-threatening
but so far I don't see a wound anywhere
on at least externally
how's Eddie doing bad yeah
and we can just do a left lateral
we're taking Addie into X-ray and we're
going to check and see what all's broken
I can clearly feel and hear even bones
crunching and moving in and around his
pelvis and his back leg so I know we
have issues there but what else
we have a fractured pelvis with a severe
dislocation of his right leg that must
have been where the car ran over him
well we know what we have it's not a
broken back it is not a severed spinal
cord or there is no quality of life for
this dog I know buddy I'll get you
get your butt 12 plus year old doggy
bones just don't heal together the same
way as younger pets I'm really concerned
that this could take a turn for the
worse for Eddie this pelvic fracture is
only compounding things
it's not a very good prognosis but it's
not one where the only Humane option is
to euthanize
[Music]
looks worse in this picture
I got dislocated hip dislocated hip
pelvic fracture oh my yeah
um how old is my pretty old dog I'm
gonna see if he would want to go
potentially have the pelvis plated and
have this have the head of the femur
pinned back in if that's not an option
today then I think we do some pain
management get him stabilized I'm gonna
go talk with Eddie's dad in the car he's
pretty shook up yeah so that's a bad one
Eddie is a super senior dog this is like
having your 90 plus year old grandma or
Grandpa break a pelvis and dislocate a
hip
okay I'm gonna go talk to Eddie's Dad
and see how he wants to proceed
all right I think I've gotten everything
clipped as best I can here Val I don't
see anything where the pelvis poked
through the skin on initial exam I used
my fingers and I pinched Dolly's hind
legs to see if I would get any movement
or pain she didn't give me much but now
I really need to use a little more
aggressive approach good girl we're
going to squeeze on the pause with the
forceps to see if we get any deep pain
if they can't feel deep pain then that
means the nerves were potentially
severed that could mean paralysis which
of course we know is a terrible thing
oh that's good I'm so happy to hear that
little line that's a great sign
she yelped and she felt that deep pain
and that's music to my ears that means
that we still have nerve function and we
have a chance of saving this leg
that's a great sign that we have deep
pain but it's a bad sign that she can't
move the right hand okay I need to go
have a conversation with your mama a
majority of the pelvic fractures that
come into our Clinic yes they're bad but
they are usually something that we can
cure with some conservative therapy do
some pain management and they get better
not this one
the car completely crushed one half of
Dolly's pelvis I'll show you the x-rays
Dolly's pelvic fracture is literally
life-threatening at this point if any of
these shards of bone
puncture the colon or puncture the
urinary bladder or any of those nerves
then we could be talking about a dog
that probably isn't going to make it and
we have to euthanize
she's in a very precarious situation at
the moment
no matter what way you look at it
foreign
she's just a good all-around dog I mean
she kind of watches out for Addison when
she was in college and you bring her to
the farm and she loves watching the cows
and helping out moving cuddle and kind
of feel like she's your
partner
I think going and seeing an orthopedic
surgeon is probably the best I really do
okay
I'll work on that and you guys want to
go visit Dolly she's right down the hall
we're definitely worried but she's
showing her hind end here yeah she's
more of a fighter than I am
if you want to just hang out with her
and keep her company I think we've
managed her shock at this point all
right I'll be right back I need to get a
hold of a surgeon as soon as possible
that deals with this all the time and
just see what our odds are here
Eddie's dad is being very realistic and
understands that putting Eddie through a
huge orthopedic surgery is just not the
right fit for their family at this time
it's a huge undertaking for an older dog
after we get through kind of the first
day or two of just getting over shock
and Trauma if it seems like he is going
to be in too much pain to try and make
it through this recovery then the best
choice for Eddie and his dad may be to
let him go
we'll just give it some more time well
anyway in on the decision too
old dogs are the best dogs yeah it's
okay
I got a hold of a great orthopedic
surgeon in Kansas and they said they
could take this on which is great news
as soon as they get everything it should
be just a matter of minutes I'll make
sure that we get you guys packed up and
ready to go I'm glad that the Vil walks
ran right up to the vet clinic with
Dolly this morning she needed emergency
care to get over all the shock and
everything that happened good luck kiddo
good job Mom yep
okay let me know I want to see pictures
I'm excited for her to hopefully start
her day of healing tomorrow with surgery
and uh this is step one I know Dolly's
got a long road ahead of her but
hopefully uh Addison's gonna have her
dog back she's one lucky dog
[Music]
I'm out the weaseler farm and they
called me out because one of their Bowls
has a foot problem or at least a leg
problem they think there he is you never
know what you're going to walk into or
drive into on that kind of situation
hello Danny hello Ben
we are dealing with a bull so we have to
be careful
so Danny you got a bull here and I heard
he has a name we've got an older one it
was all blue so the granddaughter's
named this one little blue oh that's
nice
two months ago the granddaughters were
standing next to me scratching him on
the forehead
uh he's not in that mood now
he'd never been a charging bull but he
hurts
how old is your bowl just a little over
two years old he bred some heifers last
year yep did fine now was days away from
cutting him loose with the girls again
and they come up limping here I'd love
to see him walk around a little bit okay
hey Little Blue
Danny it looks like he's toe touching
lame like he's only wanting to touch the
front part of his toe down and not his
heel this bull could have broken the
back of his heel bulb walking wrong he
could have foot rot there's lots of
things that could be going on here
we've got to just take a look and see
what we can find I do think the best
thing to do would be to set my head gate
right up in front of your alley here and
we'll walk him in okay okay so I'll go
ahead and get that set up that's why I
brought Caitlyn for all that hard work
foreign
[Music]
that's going to sedate him and we'll go
ahead and let him right back out into
that pen because this is not anything I
want to do when they're awake
[Music]
come on Blue come on Blue come on
all right Caitlin have you ever done a
tail vein stick before no all right no
first time for everything let's do this
Caitlyn's learning and the only way to
learn is to do go until you hit and get
straight in yep straight in
good you're in the vein
you get it all right good that starts
the clock now let's let him back
nice and easy nice and easy now now
we'll just be quiet and let him fall
asleep this is field surgery so I give a
sedation that lasts about 10 minutes and
I want these animals right back up on
their feet so we've got to work here I
got a coat in my back seat I think I
want something over his face and eyes so
that we don't have any stimulus
be ready in case he wants to get up
let's put that on there just in case he
fights it
oh wow little Blue's got a pretty darn
big nail sticking out of his lateral
claw here
so I've got three inches of a nail
sticking out I'm not sure how much is
actually in the foot go ahead and tie it
to that post about there yep we've got
anything from infection to tetanus which
could definitely kill him to just losing
a whole claw here out of this whole
procedure so we've got to get this nail
out we've got to get them treated see
how it goes first thing I want to do is
clean up all this debris and mud around
his hoof because we're going to
basically treat this like a sterile
surgical side at this point now I know
why it was toe touching lame right
oh Caitlyn you got it there you go see
that it was in there about a whole inch
Caitlyn was cleaning up the whole foot
and it basically just eased on out you
know Danny it's a good sign that that
nail came out that easily because if you
have to really work on them to get them
out that means they're deep in some
structures and hopefully this is our
lucky day
so now that Caitlyn got the nail out
we've got to get this whole foot
scrubbed up we're also going to spray
out that hole that this nail made with
iodine because iodine loves to kill
bacteria and right now there's a high
load of bacteria in there okay let's put
a nice wrap on here now we've just got
to get them treated we're going to use
some antibiotics some
anti-inflammatories definitely a tetanus
booster and we're going to wake them up
if we didn't get this nail out right now
he had no chance little blue that was a
big problem but I think you're going to
get better
you want to keep it
quite a souvenir I'm pretty confident
and Ben's got us on the right road to
get him on track again all cattle are
special to me that's all I live for heck
of a job Caitlin you're getting better
and better every day
so you're saying I was bad at one point
you said it
[Music]
hi little buddy
Eddie has not pulled through Ben Eddie
Eddie passed away oh no I think because
of some pre-existing age-related issues
all of the trauma of being hit by the
car pushed him over the edge he's gonna
take him to the farm and bury him there
he said I I didn't know how I was going
to take care of him and how I was going
to do all that in his passing Eddie
really took away the the burden of that
decision
from his dad
I'm very much at peace with it he was
comfortable he wasn't painful
I truly know what was coming down the
road for him and knew that would be
really difficult for an old doggie and
also for his dad to go through with him
our whole plan was to get Eddie's vote
when he was kind of out of shock and
I mean I think this was his vote
this was sort of the natural progression
and I feel like just kind of Eddie's
last gift to his dad
I don't know dogs take care of us in
amazing ways so I think Eddie made that
choice easier sometimes you take care of
your pets and sometimes
they take care of you
[Music]
thank you
hello Mike and Melanie how are you guys
good good hi I was expecting there to be
some birds there with you
we're going to do something that we
normally don't get to do around here we
drew some blood on some lovebirds Mac
and nanner mac and Nana are siblings
they live in the same cage and their
owners wanted to see if they're the same
sex or if they're opposite sex we're
gonna have a little Bird gender reveal
deal party I've never had a gender
reveal for any of my babies they were
born when this wasn't a thing we've
colored Chalk in the eggs so once we pop
the eggs open the chalk should go up in
the air and it will be a fun gender
reveal cloud of dust
that's how it's supposed to go we didn't
do any trial runs do you guys have
thoughts on if Nana's a boy or a girl
and if Max a boy or a girl I thought
nanner was the girl and Mac was the boy
well let's see if you're right okay are
you ready drum roll
one two three
oh I'm wrong
kindergarten Ben is loving this
ready guys yep three Mac is uh one
oh my God
Max a girl
Mackenzie
yeah yeah now that you guys know that we
have a male and a female bird what are
you gonna do well some sort of siblings
they'll have to be removed from each
other they're gonna have to uh to meet
their significant other outside the
family reunion
I feel like we're gonna start some
Rumors in town thinking we're gonna have
baby girl
thank you guys so much that was fun bye
all right thank you give me five no
come here
[Music]
hi
that's really funny your channel can
move faster than a boat motor yeah
you've got a prop back there yeah
no eating no eating that her heart rate
and her tail were about the same they're
both at about 120 beats per minute in
Wags per minute
please get the happy dance
oh there's our bangle
after two days at home Lily's back for
her dental let's get her out of here
that's good morning in bengalese she
hasn't been eating or drinking or
pooping and I'm sure it's all because of
this infected tooth she's gonna have to
be totally under anesthesia to get a
really good look I saw one bad tooth
there might be four she looked like she
was 9.8 pounds today so she's lost a
little bit of weight even since we've
seen her it's kind of one of those
things where damned if we do damned if
we don't because if we don't fix her
she's gonna starve to death but trying
to fix her could also kill her so
here we go
this is kind of her last chance to kind
of start feeling better
good luck guys Val and Aaron do all the
small animal dentals around here so I'm
going to pass this case off to the
experts truly in this case
let's get going okay time is of the
essence here
so Val we'll do a full set of mouth
x-rays and then we'll have to remove
anything that might have to go this is
very tedious work it's very very high
stress work we also have a very risky
cat under anesthesia I have to
concentrate
a great x-ray you can see this is a
normal canine tooth and then look at
this tooth it looks like something
almost took a bite right out of it this
is like a hole in her canine tooth down
here that's actually the middle of the
pulp of her tooth
I mean that's just raw exposed root like
if you cracked your tooth in half and
had exposed root it would make me sure
not want to eat the root is taking up
half of the space in the Jawbone this is
the tough tooth to get out
so a lot of patience just being slow
otherwise what can happen is that you
can inadvertently break the jaw just
have to take a breath
not panicked and get going on this
it's like paper mache
it's breaking
tip of a root just split off so it was
like paper
we'll react right and get it her tooth
just broke in half which means the crown
or the part above the gum just broke off
from the root or the part down in the
jaw see how much bone I have right there
if I hit that I've broken her jaw
this is not surprising this happens with
a lot of teeth especially cat teeth that
are breaking down but this does present
a huge problem and that we have to get
this root out or that will abscess and
cause continued pain
what we have to do is actually drill the
root out the problem is is that we have
less than a millimeter on each side of
that root before we break through into
the jaw bone and potentially fracture
the jaw that's so close
there it goes
I got it
it's like a half a tooth you can see
where it's all broke off
you can actually make sure we got
everything and let's sew that baby up
okay
you too you think the big moments of
your days and the things that are going
to give you the most stress and worry
are these big problems big horses big
cows big broken bones it's actually
sometimes the little things another
great x-ray Val that looks so good two
fruit structures all look great
thankfully we got through it still have
a kitty under anesthesia but the
stressful part of phase one is at least
over you guys wrapping up yet I'm
getting the thumbs up from Val that's
good she's waking up already I see her
moving oh hi pretty baby girl
hi pretty baby cat
why didn't you touch her I know she's
letting me touch her
I'm gonna take advantage of this while I
can oh he's a good girl
I'm still not gonna kiss your face
because I know better I am so relieved
we got the problem figured out
everything should be okay and this is a
great day
[Music]
they're gonna do your little toenails
you get a little drooly when you're
nervous
that's okay we'll forgive it because
you're such a good boy
come on Lily
how do you feel after that big surgery
huh feeling better yet
I think your mom and dad are excited to
see you hello you guys hi hi hi Lily
we're just gonna make sure that she goes
home and has the best r r that any good
little Bengal Kitty could get surgery
went well and this should really cure
the problem good good I'm glad to send
her home today I want her to just rest
and relax we're anxious to have her home
I bet you are you get so used to him
right there when they're missing it's
like oh yeah I missed you buddy I was
very worried she's old she's 14. it
helps a lot if you have faith in your
doctors we knew she was in good hands
this doesn't just happen overnight but
now she needs to really start eating
again now that we've removed that
painful tooth that should start
happening I need to send you guys home
with some pain medication and we're also
going to have you guys try an appetite
stimulant that'd be good so that
hopefully she'll start eating a little
bit better on her own and get her
strength back
thank you very much absolutely good to
see you guys again tell Aaron thank you
of course I will
[Music]
yeah good boy cash is a four-month-old
golden retriever who we've seen here
since he was a puppy
what's you doing Monster
all right Val what's going on with cash
yeah my owners dropped him off this
morning he was staying with their family
members and he vomit up a sock okay
missing the second sock yeah those
usually come in twos there was some
vomiting and then nothing today he is
wanting to eat he ate this morning how's
he been feeling laying around okay are
you lethargic you're usually a wild man
why'd you eat socks
how's your tummy
[Music]
this feels a little unusual
I feel like I'm
squeezing
a hand towel
what is that I'm not sure if we have
something stuck in there if it's just
food but there is a little section that
seems a little more doughy than normal
why don't we go back and we'll snap a
couple x-rays see what we see I know we
did get a breakfast but that's been
about three hours ago so his stomach
should be pretty empty from just
breakfast time
let's go see if you only ate one sock
or if you ate a whole sock drawer when
something gets stuck inside an animal's
GI tract it can basically plug up the
whole works all right cash
see what you got but if it works its way
down into the intestine and gets into a
place where it can't move forward or
backward that can be extremely
life-threatening because that intestine
can start to have loss of blood supply
if it's stretched too tight
he has a tummy full of something
and a whole bunch of gas-filled
intestines
shouldn't be like that Cash's x-rays are
concerning to me I don't know if this is
another sock or some compacted food but
I know this is abnormal we may need to
go open up cash and do an abdominal
exploratory and see if we can figure out
what is going on inside this tummy but
hopefully this is just a gastritis hey
Casper here's cashy gastritis is an
inflammation of the stomach lining
generally this heals on its own or with
some medical treatment so I have one
more thing I want to try before we have
to jump to surgery have you ever heard
of like a barium study basically what we
would do is we would give with some
canned food a big dose of this liquid it
kind of looks like chalky milk like a
milkshake as it moves through the DI
tract it shows up very very bright on
the X-ray we can see if it can't get out
of the stomach we know we have an
obstruction or if it can't make it
through a part of the intestine we know
we have a problem if everything all goes
through we can all kind of sleep well
and know that he probably just had a
very bad gastritis are you okay to try
that yeah I'd be willing to try that
are you hungry cashy oh my goodness do
you smell food
we're feeding barium with a little bit
of yummy dog food to cash we're gonna
make you a special cash cocktail and
then we do a series of timed x-rays to
really watch that barium inside that GI
tract so that looks so good
as he eats the slurry here this is all
radio pink so when we take an x-ray
it'll show up really bright white and
we'll be able to make sure all of this
goes through his GI tract valuables for
you buddy
now we just wait
hello I'm Melinda this is Dr Ben from
Cedar County Vet how are you
we just wanted to check in on Dolly and
see how she's doing after her surgery
dolly is a young Australian Shepherd
that came in with one of the worst
pelvic fractures I've ever seen oh my
goodness this is beyond belief we sent
it off to an orthopedic surgeon in
Kansas it's been a few weeks now so it's
time for an update is completely healed
up and she's just doing wonderful well
I'm so glad that Dolly's doing better
everybody around here is curious they
want to see some pictures or even a
video do you mind sending something
today we can definitely do that I am
really just beyond belief oh wow this is
the best news of my day check this out
Tails wagon she's moving around remember
when she came in the first morning she
couldn't even move one of her legs yeah
she looks like a real dog again yeah she
looked better than before she looks like
she's totally healed up that's a little
doggy miracle
okay I have to go do work all right love
you you actually have to help me do work
you can't just watch dog videos all day
oh look at her I'm serious
[Music]
hey did you get a cat toy no don't eat
it it's time to take another x-ray of
cash in a perfect world I'd see a
beautiful empty stomach intestines all
where they're supposed to be food moving
through the intestines time for your
picture
fingers crossed let's see what we got
Val
yay look at that stomach it is back to
being small you have a big berry and
poop waiting to come out the X-ray then
his tummy's empty and it's back to
normal size we're gonna go tell Dad the
good news no surgery for you cashy no
more socks either
Daddy's here we get to go show him how
good you feel Casper is back to pick up
cash who appears only ate one sock in my
washing machine have something in common
we got good news I think he had a very
bad gastritis from eating the stock and
then vomiting the sock and the lining of
their stomach can get really inflamed I
think he just was really irritated and
things were kind of all out of whack
because of the sock situation because
cash was always sort of bouncy and happy
I'm really glad we were able to take a
more conservative approach do the barium
study and I feel great so he's pretty
happy dog I think he's just ready to go
home awesome I'm ready to have him home
yeah no more socks good luck with him
yeah you have a very active toddler
thank you yep good luck come on cash
thank you yeah bye-bye
[Music]
all right I see Maple's flowers are
coming apart she's got a little bit of
uh spunk this morning we're at shoots
and Fest in Beau Valley Nebraska
it only happens once every five years
because we have such a big party it
takes five years to recover
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
and we got all these Mountain areas
owned by Ben and Aaron Schrader hi good
morning
[Music]
good morning guys
just to watch The Joy on all the kids
faces when they're seeing you and Mabel
[Music]
you little girl for her second time
being on a halter she just took to it
like uh bees on a flower flies on poo I
don't know she was really good girl
it's so cool being here at shoots and
Fest because we know everybody here you
guys look right by the way thanks from
their cow herds to their dogs or cats
that they bring in it's truly a whole
County that gets together for this
shoots inside schmutes and Fest yeah
[Applause]
[Music]